[Music]
everyone knows that when you turn a book
into a TV show or movie the product is
never quite the same
stay tuned for some of the most shocking
differences between the books and the
show ever if you're a huge movie buff
make sure you check out our sister
channel Screen Rant and subscribe for
new videos now on to ten differences
between Shadowhunters books and TV show
the characters if you are a die-hard fan
of The Mortal Instruments series then
you have probably noticed some serious
differences between the books and the
show Shadowhunters to get things started
let's talk about the most basic
difference the characters almost all of
them are at least a little bit different
from their literacy counterparts take
Luke for instance and the books
Luke lived on top of a bookshop and
lived a super quiet life in the show he
is a police officer whose life is
nowhere near as quiet and the books
marine isn't introduced until City of
Fallen Angels but in the series she
appears in the very first episode and is
said to be one of Clarion Simon's
friends which wasn't the case in the
book and don't make us start talking
about Lydia Branwell she's not even in
the books she was just added to the show
to lead alec into having a relationship
with Magnus and if you really want to
get down to details all of the
characters on the show are a lot older
than they were in the books Clary was
supposed to be almost 16 when she first
met Jace Isabel and Jace were also 16
but in the show Alec is 23 and the rest
of the cast is around the same age
scenes it's not just the characters that
are way different in the show than they
are in the books some of the scenes are
different as well take how Alec felt
when he had to marry Lydia Branwell in
the show this never happened in the
books Alec was never supposed to marry
anyone in the books and the relationship
between Isabelle and Raphael that turned
up in season two did not happen like
that at all but we like them together so
we aren't too upset about it all of the
scenes with Maddy are different from the
way things went in the books even though
we like some of the changes that they
made before bringing the characters to
life it's kind of strange to see the
storylines veer especially if you are a
super fan like we are we thought we
would know how everything would turn out
after reading the books but that is not
the case at all how do the changes in
the scenes make you feel are you
screaming at the television or are you
happy with the changes make sure to let
us know your feelings in the comments
Clary okay so we know that Clary is the
main character and everything but did
you like her in the books a lot of
readers had issues with her because of
how she acted towards other female
characters in the books she doesn't
really get along with Izzy and that
would normally be fine but it seems like
the reason they didn't get along was
that Clary was jealous in the TV show
their relationship is quite different
the two seem to be friends from the
start Clary is also a lot closer to her
mom on the show than she was in the
books as well it could be due to the
fact that TV query is older than book
Clary and probably appreciates her mom a
bit more than book Clary
in the show Clary also has a lot more
going for her than in the books at the
beginning of the show she's accepted
into an advanced program at the Brooklyn
Academy of Art talked about ambition
again this difference possibly occurs
due to her age at 15 it probably would
be a little hard for Clary to be
accepted into such a prestigious program
which do you like better
the book version of Clary or the TV
Clary Simon poor Simon he showed up a
lot more in the books than he did on the
TV show in the books he was a geeky
mortal for quite a while it wasn't until
the second book that he transformed into
a vampire and was sired by Rafael so we
got to know his character a lot better
on the television show he was
transformed in the first season and it
wasn't even at the end of the season
either it was in episode three on the
show Camille who was a vampire let's
time invite her while they were making
out a lot of people who were fans of the
books were super mad about this
diversion why because having Simon
changed so early meant that so many
other things in the books would have to
change so much will have to be cut out
because Simon is already a vampire so if
you were looking forward to seeing any
of Simon's non-vampire moments on screen
then you are not
to be a happy camper but this does mean
that we are going to get to see a lot
more of vampire Simon than we did in the
books and who knows maybe people like it
this way better jobs watching the
Shadowhunter show is like playing a game
of Clue to figure out what they changed
from the books and what they added in if
you read the books and now watch the
show you will notice that there is a
huge difference in the jobs of a lot of
the characters in the books
Clary's mom Jocelyn is an artist but you
may have forgotten this because in the
show she owns an antique store they may
have done this because they wanted
Clary's mom to look like she had a more
stable job but we are not 100% certain
why this change occurred as we mentioned
before lugar Way owns a bookstore in the
books which made sense because it
matched his sword of meek personality
but in the show he is an officer with
the NYPD
this wouldn't have made sense in the
books but somehow on the show it makes
perfect sense another weird thing is
that on the show Simon is an accounting
student which isn't exactly a profession
but in the books he is a high school
student we wonder what the reason for
all these switches was where the
television writers just bored and
wanting to shake things up a bit
glamouring okay so changing ages and
small things about characters makes
sense sometimes after all the show could
be half as sultry as it is if all the
characters were actually sixteen on the
show that would just be creepy but when
the writers change a whole storyline
that's when it can get a bit too much
one time that occurred was in episode 10
of the television show when the truth
about Michael Wayland was exposed Jase
recognized him as his father immediately
this was because Valentine had glamoured
himself to look like Michael but in the
books this hold reveal went a bit
differently in the written series
Valentine didn't change his appearance
to look like Michael he only took on
Michael's name and identity which caused
Jase not to instantly recognize him
maybe they were running out of time on
the show and it needed to speed up the
process or maybe it's a bit harder to
show things that are described in books
whereas in the book they could describe
how Jay slowly began to recognize
Michael but in the show that's a little
bit harder to portray this version was
probably much easier for an audience to
digest Jase and Valentine's relationship
every relationship is different from
chips to romantic relationships it all
comes down to how both people feel about
one another some relationships on the
show are quite different from the ones
in the books which relationship are we
talking about in particular the one
between Jace and Valentine in the books
Jace thinks about teaming up with
Valentine and working with him although
he thinks about it he never really
voices these intentions he also never
actually does team up with Valentine on
the television show that is not the case
at the end of season 1 Jace does decide
to team up with Valentine granted there
was some coercion involved with that
decision but at the end of the day Jace
does work with Valentine which makes us
wonder how this will cause the future of
the show to differ from the book it's
kind of like a chain of events one
change causes 1,000 others will this
difference completely change the way
that Jace is feature goes on the show it
definitely has the potential to cause
some big waves such a big partnership
cannot happen without repercussions we
guess we will have to stay tuned to find
out how everything shakes out in the end
the mortal cup if you were just watching
Shadowhunters and hadn't read the books
you might not have any problems with the
storyline but for those of us who are
diehard fans of the books we have more
than a few issues one for instance is
the fact that the mortal cup has a
completely different use in a series
than it did in the books granted the
mortal cup is pretty important in both
versions on the show they say that if a
human has a drink from the cup they will
die which is really strange because in
the book if a human drinks from the cup
they will transform into a Shadowhunter
it also is a lot more valuable in the
show than it was in the books in the
show lots of Downworlders want the cup
but in the book only a few people wanted
it another thing that was different on
the show was the number of times that
Clary used to the cup in the book Clary
never used the cup to control any demons
on the TV show she does it quite often
Clary use of the cop does make the show
a bit more interesting to watch so we
can see why the show's creators would
change the script like that Jocelyn so
in the show
Jocelyn gave Clary a steal at the
beginning of the show which was strange
because the books
Jocelyn would have never done that
Jocelyn didn't want Clary to know
anything about the shadow world
so her giving Clary the steel makes no
sense whatsoever
always super careful to make sure that
Clary wasn't exposed to anything
supernatural in fact she was so
concerned with Clary never finding out
about the magical elements of the world
that she went to Magnus to have him get
rid of Cleary's memories so that she
wouldn't remember anything about the
shadow world
so her giving her the steel actually
goes against everything she has done in
the past this show also had Jocelyn
passed away for some reason in the books
Jocelyn ever passed away so it was weird
when the show would make up such a huge
thing and it didn't even really matter
to the storyline it's like the writers
just got bored and we're like who can we
get rid of today and for some reason
that person was Jocelyn lots of fans of
the books had a big problem with the way
the show handled Jocelyn but the
creators of the show must have had a
reason for doing it more about the
characters okay we don't know about you
but when we write the books we'd like to
pay close attention to the details
especially when the author is describing
the characters it's the first time you
get a feel for who the characters are
and it's the only time you get to create
images of them in your head when the
show creators read through the books
they must have not paid too close
attention to the details of the
characters or maybe they didn't read the
books at all if they would have they
would have known that rad nor fell was
supposed to be green in the show he's
not green at all but just a regular
human tone in the books Katerina is
supposed to be blue if you've watched
the show then you know that that isn't
the case on Shadowhunters
of course these are minor changes that
don't really affect the storyline at all
but it's still annoying wouldn't have
made such a difference if the show's
creators had stuck to the storyline no
it wouldn't have it just would have made
fans of the book a lot more happy right
do you hear that producers it's not too
late your fans will thank you
and that's it for 10 differences between
Shadowhunters books and TV show did we
miss any of the differences let us know
in the comments and don't forget to
check out our sister channel Screen Rant
thanks for watching